voilà un film qui tourne à ce que vous
êtes là bonjour vous arrivez bien vous
savez quand on vient de commencer une
partie de colin-maillard avec casimir
on n'est joué avec où on venait jamais
au casimir ça y est on ne me dit rien ne
me dit rien c'est je n'ai reconnu c'est
monsieur du snop qui s'est mis à genoux
ces messieurs les stocks tu essaies tu
es sûr et certain ah oui les médias
genou alors dû regarde regarde ces
messieurs du snav
je dirais que c'est monsieur sinon ça
c'est michael a
je me suis trompé tu as perdu casimir
tueur à gages qu'est ce qu'on lui fait
comme gage ans n'ont pas ce gars n'ont
pas de gages 1,6 et casimir sont des
soins qu'ils allaient sauter sur pied à
la corde soturac et casimir
quand c'est trop fatiguant à l'écran la
corde
bonne idée les a jamais y arriver un peu
de place parce que je savais qu'il faut
de la santé allez allez voir ce que tu
as à faire des choses comme ça à notre
gardien qui chantait ont fait chanter
meilleur ça c'est une bonne idée alors
on s'assied 1 on s'assied à tout le
monde par terre et on est beaucoup mieux
dans les airs devant lalalala voisins
vont me faire faire encore tout le monde
dans l'herbe la la qu'est ce qu'on lui
fait chanter comme chance au hockey ou
des mails au coeur de alors qu'elle
entame enfin c'est pas bon de leur
lésion finaux et neurologie alors
j'appelle les frères
c'est minable qu'est-ce qui pourrait
chanter à peu près correctement j'ai du
bon tabac allait alléger un tabac haché
du bon sabine j'ai une meilleure idée
c'est ce qu'on a fait il va nous chanter
sa chanson la chanson de kazim est ma
chanson à moi nous chante la chanson la
chanson de la connaît bien
faut espérer les dorengt aller d'accord
[Musique]
avec une chanson imagination je vous
emmène dans nos prix il a promis du
bonheur tranquille
je sois y est terrorisée je suis le
monde tiberi
map est quasiment
[Musique]
orange je suis aussi tout cas hors jeu
si l'on me dit maladroit ou
scène
je sais jouer de la musique
je suis née et se maintenir camille si
j'aime la glace aux anchois
c'est pourquoi même endroit avec une
chanson un peu imaginent
ormeno dans notre it is au pays du
bonheur tranquille
ces couleurs incompris
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
je m'appelle casimir j'ai eu une
manoeuvre
une idée forte ligne je mange
ou bing à mieux
cinéma hongrois avec une chanson
imagina
[Musique]
c'est tout
pays tout entier
vert
ne soyez pas des roses
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
kazim j'étais très bien
il était très bien ton gage quasi mais
bravo
[Musique]